ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY.
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE.
LOW MOAN LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAMOS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH.
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
[inaudible]
MR COOLEY.
ABOUT YOUR HEADS [inaudible]
ALMIGHTY GOD.
THIS THURSDAY MARCH THE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOURTH
ANNIVERSARY OF OUR NATIONS
FOUNDING. TO PURSUE THE VISION
EXPRESSED IN THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE.
ADOPTED BY CONGRESS IN
PHILADELPHIA ON JULY FOURTH.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX IN AN ERA
WHEN THE MOST PROMINENT AMERICAN
GLOBAL DIALOGUES.
REVOLVE MORE AROUND THE RISE OF
STRONG MAN RUMORS.
AND LESS ABOUT NURTURING AND
CHAMPIONING CONSTITUTIONAL AND
REPRESENT DEMOCRACIES.
IT IS LITTLE WONDER THAT SO MANY
GLOBAL CITIZENS FIRST. FOR
AMERICA'S ASPIRATIONAL.
BUT NONE THE LESS UNABLE
FOUNDING VISION.
THAT WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF EVIDENT.
THAT ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL.
THAT THEY ARE ENDOWED BY THEIR
CREATOR.
WITH CERTAIN UNALIENABLE RIGHTS.
THAT AMONG THESE ARE LIFE
LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
ALMIGHTY GOD ON THIS OCCASION
TURN OUR THOUGHTS TO YOU.
THE CREATOR WHO'S GOOD PURPOSES
FOR ALL HUMANKIND.
FORM THE BASIS FOR UNDERSTANDING
OF THE VALUE OF EVERY HUMAN LIFE.
THUNDERBIRDS THE GREAT AMERICAN
VISION.
ON THIS DAY -- GOD BE PRESENT
HERE IN THESE CHAMBERS.
AND CONVEY TO ALL HEARTS ON THIS.
FOR THE ASSURANCE THAT.
LIKE IN THE PARABLE OF THE
SECRETLY GROWING SEED EXPRESSED
IN MARK'S GOSPEL.
WELL WE ON THIS CARPET BANDIED
PLANT GOOD SEED.
IT IS YOU'RE WORKING IN AND
THROUGH HISTORY.
SUPPORTING POSITIVE LABORS OF
COMPASSION LEADERS.
AND NOT THWARTED BY THE SCHEMING
OF DESPOTS.
WHICH ENABLE US TO CONSTANTLY
DECLARE.
THE ARC OF HISTORY BINS TOWARDS
JUSTICE.
WE KNOW -- GOD MOST HIGH BECAUSE
YORK OF HISTORY IS YOUR ARC.
IN BEEN TORTURE OWN HEART OF
UNFAILING COMPASSION.
AS WE CELEBRATE THE TOURING
FORTY FOURTH ANNIVERSARY
NATION'S FOUND IN THIS WEEK.
WE ASK YOUR BLESSING UPON OUR
NATION.
GRANT OH LORD THAT DESPITE THE
TEMPESTUOUS TIMES.
WE LIVE IN.
THE DIVISION OF PRESIDENT
LINCOLN WHO LOOKS DOWN UPON US
WOULD BE SUSTAINED.
AND THAT IN THAT IN THIS
UNFOLDING THIRD CENTURY OF
AMERICAN INDEPENDENCE.
THAT GOVERNMENT OF THE PEOPLE.
BY THE PEOPLE FOR THE PEOPLE
SHALL NOT PERISH FROM THE EARTH.
MAY THESE UNITED STATES IN THIS
TWO HUNDRED FORTY FOURTH YEAR OF
OUR INDEPENDENCE.
BY YOUR GRACE ETERNAL POWER AND
THE JUSTICE PERFECT YOUR
CHARACTER -- GOD MOST HIGH.
REMAIN A BEACON OF FREEDOM TO
THE WHOLE EARTH.
A MAN.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER KALRA.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
STATES OF AMERICA [inaudible]
IT IS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE
TWENTIETH TWENTY NINETEEN ONLY
MINUTE NINE AM ON WILL KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM THIS ON
THE PRESIDING CHEAP CLICKY
DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK
READING QUICK HAPPENING AND
LOUIS READING THE ROLL CALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FUNDED A QUORUM
CALL THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION.
CALDERON MOVES.
AMOS LACKEY SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUFFY WAKES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BORN HARDBACK. TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY HER GUESTS WILL
BE SEATED AT A DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
SKEWS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN MEMORIES ALSO
SPEAKER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILL
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM.
SIXTY SEVEN SEVEN SB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN JONES AN ITEM SIXTY EIGHT
SB SIX SEVENTY ONE HERTZBERG.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
PLEASE RETURN ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN A. B. TWELVE THIRTY
FOUR PATTERSON TO THE SENATE FOR
FURTHER ACTION.
THE CLERK WILL AGAIN NO.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND A SYMBOL FIFTY SIX TO
ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FOR
THE HEARING ON TUESDAY JULY
NINTH.
SB ONE ATKINS PENDING RE REFER A
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE IN SB FOUR SEVENTY TWO
COVER YELLOW AND SB SIX NINETEEN
HUESO PENDING RE REFER ALL FROM
THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT ROLE SIXTY TWO A
THE FONG NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE TO HEAR SB FIVE OH
FIVE NUMBER.
AT THE HEARING ON WEDNESDAY JULY
THIRD.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW
THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO
NOTICE BILLS PENDING REFERRAL.
TO ALLOW THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE TO NOTICE
SB SIX SEVENTY SIX BRADFORD FOR
THEIR JULY TENTH HEARING PENDING
REFERRAL WE WERE FOR ALL FROM
THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER [inaudible]
ALSO.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
ISN'T SUSPEND A SINGLE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW.
THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE SB FIVE FORTY JONES FROM
FOR THEIR JULY TENTH HEARING
PENDING RE REFER ALL FROM THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT WILL SIXTY TWO A THE FILE
NOTICE CRIME AND TO ALLOW THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO HEAR IN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO
HOLD THE JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING.
ON WEDNESDAY JULY THIRD AT
ELEVEN AM IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TWO WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS MAY HAVE RETENTION.
WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST WITH US.
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALES.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS CHAIR THE
LATINO CAUCUS I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME TODAY INTERNS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO CAPITAL
ASSOCIATION FOUNDATION.
EVERY SUMMER GROUP OF TEN HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERN FOR AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATE SENATOR
ORRIN ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION IN
SACRAMENTO. ONE OF THEM ARE THE
WILL BE INTERVIEWING INTERNING
AT MY OFFICE THE C. L. CA AB
SUMMER INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
STRIVES TO PROVIDE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS PARTICULARLY THOSE FROM
UNDERSERVED.
COMMUNITIES A CHANCE AGAIN I
MEAN FOR PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE
IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
THESE INTERNS ARE TRAINED MENTOR
AND SUPPORTED BY EXPERIENCE
CAPITAL STAFF PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING CLC EIGHT F. INTERNS
TO THE CAPITAL
MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL TWENTY SEVEN SENATE
BILLS WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL FORTY TWO THREE SEVENTY
FIVE FOUR SEVENTY ONE SOME
816-383-13390 861-366-7270 SIX
THREE SIXTY ONE ONE THREE NINE
AND SIX THIRTY NINE ALL BILLS
HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
[inaudible]
EVERYBODY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
BILLS ON CONCURRENCE.
BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN AB.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN OPERATE.
AS A LEGAL ONE TWENTY SEVEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER LACKEY AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE GOING THERE TO SEE
ARE THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MR LACKEY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT AB ONE TWENTY SEVEN
WHICH OF COURSE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE PROVIDES TECHNICAL
FIX IT'S NOT NO NO VOTES WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISS LACKEY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLICK OVER THE ROLE.
NUMBER SERVICE ADAMO ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
LOCAL CLOSER ON TIE VOTE.
I SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM. SIXTEEN PASS RETAIN FILE
ITEMS SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN WE
ARE FOLLOWED IN NINETEEN A. B..
SIX ONE EIGHT BY MISTER STONE.
CORRECT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTEEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER MARK STONE AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO TAXATION.
MR STONE YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THEN AMENDMENTS ADD THE CITY OF
EMERYVILLE AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS
OF IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
TO DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ICE FORTY
THREE KNOWS FOURTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TWENTY PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY ONE AB TWELVE NINETY TWO
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARRICADE HAN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE FIRE ARMS.
MS BARRICADE HAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWELVE NINETY TWO IS
BACK ON CONCURRENT FROM THE
SENATE THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
SENATE SIDE.
SIMPLY CLARIFY WHO FALLS INTO
OPERATION OF LAW FOR TRANSFER OF
A FIREARM TO INCLUDE A TRUSTEE
CONSERVATOR A GUARDIAN AD LITEM
ESPECIALLY MINISTRY -- OR
GUARDIAN APPOINTED BY THE COURT
BY CLARIFYING UPDATING WE'RE
MAKING SURE GOOD ACTORS ARE NOT
PENALIZED DUE TO OUT OF DATE
LAWS THIS BILLS HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO NO BUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER QUE HAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT ABOUT [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRED IN
.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO IS AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AND
ACTUALLY THE FAMILY LAW.
MR STONE YOU MAY GET OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS THE
ANNUAL.
JUDICIARY -- OMNIBUS BILL FOR
FAMILY LAW THE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE JUST CHATTERING OUT
AMENDMENTS I ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
AMOS DOWN SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE OUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES.
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM.
SIXTEEN A. B. TEN SIXTY TWO
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TEN SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW MULLIN AND
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
MS LAMONT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TEN
SIXTY TWO IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
A. B. TEN SIXTY TWO WILL PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECEIVE HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
CREDITS.
AND PARTICIPATE IN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND BASIC RESPONSE
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
SKILLS NEEDED TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND ASSIST OTHERS IN
THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MONSIGNOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
WELL.
ZARA BUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE IS AB.
FIVE THIRTY SEPARATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO THE
FAIRFIELD SYSOON SEWER DISTRICT
CLING THERE AND SEE THEIR US
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FIVE THIRTY
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE THIS IS THE DISTRICT
BILL TO SUPPORT THE ACTIVITIES
OF THE FAIRFIELD TOO SOON SEWER
DISTRICT.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITHOUT ANY
NO VOTES I RESPECT LEAVE US FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB.
FIVE THIRTY THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY C. NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
WELL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER CEREMONY
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THAT I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN IN THE BILL'S FINAL
FORM.
ON MOTION RECONSIDER ITEM TWENTY
FOUR AND TWENTY FIVE ARE TO BE
CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WHERE THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEMS TWENTY
SIX THROUGH [inaudible]
THIRTY ONE PAST RETAIN.
WE'RE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY TWO AJ ARE FOURTEEN BY MR
LACKEY CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
FOURTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
LACKEY AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS.
MR LACKEY.
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE YOUR ATTENTION AS
LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AJ
FOURTEEN RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS.
AND THE IMPACT YOU ORGANIZATIONS
HAD ON ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS HAVE A
HIGHLIGHTED WHAT ATHLETES CAN
ACCOMPLISH INSTEAD OF WHAT THEY
CANNOT.
IT FOCUSES ON HOW OUR
DIFFERENCES CAN BRING US
TOGETHER INSTEAD OF DIVIDING US.
THROUGH EVENTS THAT ARE HELD
YEAR ROUND INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES ARE ENCOURAGED TO
COMPETE IN A WIDE RANGE OF
ATHLETIC ENDEAVOR SUPPORTED BY.
VOLUNTEERS FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SUMMER
GAMES JUST CONCLUDED -- THIS
LAST WEEKEND AND SAW SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTY ATHLETES WITH
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE COACHES
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
THE SPECIAL EFFECTS AS FAR MORE
THAN JUST REFINED PHYSICAL
SKILLS.
IT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO HELP THE
MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL WELL BEING
OF THE ATHLETES INCLUDING
PROVIDING NEW SOCIALIZATION
OPPORTUNITIES EDUCATIONAL EQUITY.
I CREATING BASS TO BEHAVIORAL
BENEFITS.
THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS IS SO MUCH
BIGGER THAN A VOLUNTEER
OPPORTUNITY OR SOMETHING TO DO
ON WEEKENDS IT HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO CHANGE THE LIVES OF NEARLY.
SIX HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND HOW
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
IN OUR STATE.
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE TOO
OFTEN FORGOTTEN SACRAMENTO.
AND I'LL CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
THESE MEMBERS OF ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR AS LONG AS I'M
HERE.
AS YOU WORK TOWARD THE GOOD OF
ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS LET'S
REMEMBER TO SUPPORT EACH OTHER
BY LOOKING FOR THE LONELY
ISOLATED.
LEFT OUT AND THE BULLY THE TO
OVERCOME THE FEAR OF DIFFERENCE
TO REPLACE IT WITH THE POWER OF
INCLUSION.
LET'S CHOOSE TO INCLUDE AND
MISTER SPEAKER WHAT THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO OPEN THE FIRST ROLL CALL
FOR FOR OTHERS.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM THE AUTHORS ASSN THAT
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON AJ ARE
FOURTEEN THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL. ZERO THEIR SEVENTY
ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS AN
H. A R. WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE.
SEVERAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VERY SAD ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY THREE THROUGH.
THIRTY SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE.
SENATE THIRD READING.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY EIGHT SB.
FORTY ONE CARBURETOR.
SAMPLE FORTY ONE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO DAMAGES.
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN A FOUR YEAR OLD BOY A
SOUGHT DAMAGES BECAUSE HE
SUFFERED NEUROLOGICAL DAMAGE
AFTER LIVING IN APARTMENT
ILLEGALLY COATED WITH LEAD PAINT.
WHILE THE BOYS ATTORNEYS
ESTIMATED HE SHOULD BE AWARDE
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
THE AMOUNT HE WOULD HAVE EARNED
OVER HIS LIFETIME THE LANDLORDS
ATTORNEYS ARGUED HE SHOULD ONLY
BE AWARDED ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION.
BECAUSE AS A LATINO HE WAS
UNLIKELY TO ATTAIN THE ADVANCE
EDUCATION THAT WAS TO GARNER THE
LARGER INCOME.
THIS PRACTICE IS UNCONSCIONABLE
INDIVIDUAL SHOULD NOT BE VALUED
BASED ON IMMUTABLE
CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS RACE OR
GENDER.
YEAH UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING TO
PLAINTIFFS IN CALIFORNIA
COURTROOMS.
BECAUSE WOMEN AFRICAN AMERICANS
LATINOS AND OTHERS BURN LESS ON
AVERAGE THAN THEIR WHITE AND
MALE COUNTERPARTS THE DAMAGES
THEY CAN RECEIVE IN THESE
LAWSUITS CAN BE SUBSTANTIALLY
LOWER.
SB FORTY ONE WOULD MAKE OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM MORE FAIR BY
PUTTING AN END TO THE WIDESPREAD
PRACTICE USED BY LEGAL DEFENSE
TEAMS TO SHORT CHANGE PLAINTIFFS.
IN PERSONAL INJURY AND WRONGFUL
DEATH CASES BASED ON RACE AND
GENDER.
IN THESE CASES JUDGES AND JURIES
RELY ON CALCULATION TABLES THAT
ECONOMISTS USE TO PROTECT THE
PLAINTIFFS LOST EARNINGS AND
WAGES BASED ON FEDERAL
STATISTICS THAT BREAK DOWN
FUTURE EARNINGS ALONG RACE IN
GENERAL LINES.
ALL CALIFORNIA PLAINTIFFS
DESERVE TRUE JUSTICE ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO SERVICE STATE
THE DON'T LET THE COURTS VALUE
PEOPLE BASED ON THE GENDER ON
THEIR GENDER OR THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER TO SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
[inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF RESERVE VOTE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
BURKE WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FORTY S. J. R. [inaudible]
FOR TRIGGERING.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FOR BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO TITLE.
TEN MS PETRIE-NORRIS YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. J. R..
FOR STR AFFIRMS CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPORT FOR TITLE TEN OUR
COUNTRY'S LANDMARK PROGRAM FOR
AFFORDABLE BIRTH CONTROL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
TITLE TEN ENSURES THAT EVERY
WOMAN.
WHATEVER HER INCOME WHETHER SHE
CAN AFFORD HEALTH INSURANCE HAS
ACCESS TO BASIC PREVENTIVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
INCLUDING BIRTH CONTROL
INCLUDING CANCER SCREENINGS
INCLUDING STD TESTING AND
TREATMENT.
IN MARCH THE TRUMP AT PENCE
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED THEIR
TITLE TEN DOT CRAWL.
THIS GAG RULE WILL REMOVE ALL
FEDERAL FUNDING FRIEND ANY
PROVIDER WHO PROVIDES
COUNSELLING REFERRALS OR
PERFORMS ABORTIONS SERVICES.
THIS IS A DEVASTATING BLOW TO
THE ONE MILLION CALIFORNIA WOMEN
AND MILLIONS MORE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO RELY ON TITLE TEN
FOR CRITICAL HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
THIS IS NOT HEALTHCARE POLICY
THIS IS PLAIN POLITICS WITH
WOMEN'S LIVES.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR WOMEN WE
WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE.
COLLEAGUES TODAY I ASK YOU TO
STAND WITH ME TO SUPPORT AS
CHAIR FOR TO SUPPORT WOMEN AND
WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE TO SUPPORT
TITLE TEN PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THAT.
MS REST YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SJ ARE FOR
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
CONNIE LEIVA FOR OFFERING SUCH A
CRITICAL RESOLUTION.
TOTAL TEN FUNDING SERVES
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ALLOWING THEM
ACCESS TO SAFE.
COMPASSIONATE AND FINANCIALLY
ACCESSIBLE HEALTH CARE THAT THEY
NEED.
THE SERVICES AS MY COLLEAGUES
INDICATED INCLUDE BIRTH CONTROL
S. T. D. TESTING SEXUAL
EDUCATION AND CANCER SCREENINGS
WHICH ARE CRITICAL TO THE WELL
BEING OF MEN AND WOMEN ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
TITLE TEN AS A PLATFORM TO
PROVIDE TO WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES WITH CRITICAL FAMILY
PLANNING RESOURCES.
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE NEW TITLE TEN REGULATIONS.
THE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
HURTING FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.%
I URGE MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO STAND UP.
AND SPEAK OUT ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS J. R..
FOUR THANK YOU IS REYES.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE RESOLUTION.
IS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK AT
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND WOULD LIKE
THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU.
THING IS PETRIE-NORRIS WITH THAT
THE CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE.
WALKERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON S. J. R. FOUR THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE FIFTY ONE
CO AUTHORS ADDED.
THIS IS AN S. J. ARE WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
AS ROLE.
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
TWELVE THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM FORTY ONE PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS FORTY TWO
THROUGH.
FORTY FIVE WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX SB THIRTY CORKERY.
SENATE BILL THIRTY BY SENATOR
WIENER AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP.
THIS FEATURE NOR SHOULD MAKE AN
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR SB THIRTY SENATE BILL THIRTY
EXPANDS CALIFORNIANS OPTIONS TO
ENTER INTO LEGALLY PROTECTED
RELATIONSHIPS BY REMOVING THE
GENDERED REQUIREMENTS OF COUPLES
WHO WISH TO BECOME PARTNERS.
CURRENTLY TO REGISTER AS A
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
A COUPLE MUST EITHER BE SAME SEX
OR OPPOSITE SEX IF ONE PARTNER
IS OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY TWO THE
HISTORICAL REASON FOR THIS IS
BECAUSE LGBT Q. COUPLES COULD
NOT PREVIOUSLY GOT MARRIED.
SO THEY WERE GIVEN THE OPTION TO
REGISTER AS DOMESTIC PARTNERS
OLDER OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES WERE
ALSO GIVEN THIS PRIVILEGE
BECAUSE OF SOCIAL SECURITY
CONSIDERATIONS.
AND BECAUSE OLDER COUPLES MORE
FREQUENTLY LIVE ON A FIXED
INCOME.
NOW WE CAN FORTUNATELY ALL GET
MARRIED AND WE SHOULD ALL ALSO
BE ABLE TO ENTER INTO A DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIP IF WE SO CHOOSE.
IN MODERN LIFE PEOPLE MAKE ALL
SORTS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
CHOICES REFLECTING THEIR VALUES
COMMITMENTS AND LONG TERM PLANS.
SB THIRTY REMOVES DISCRIMINATORY
BARRIERS FOR COUPLES WHO WISH TO
BE CALM DOMESTIC PARTNERS IN
RECOGNIZES AND RESPECTS THEIR
RIGHT TO CHOOSE THEIR OWN
DEFINITION OF THEIR RELATIONSHIP.
NOT EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA WANTS
TO BE MARRIED BUT MANY DO YOU
WANT THEIR RELATIONSHIPS AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO BE RECOGNIZED
AND TO HAVE LEGAL PROTECTIONS.
THIS BILL ENABLES PEOPLE'S
FREEDOM TO MAKE CHOICES ABOUT
THEIR OWN RELATIONSHIP THE BILL
IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN THE SENATE AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU IS PETRIE-NORRIS
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS.
THIS OUT OF THAT ALL MEMBERS OF
A RESERVE THE ALL MEMBERS ARE
DESIRABLE
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TELEVOTE
EYES.
FIFTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FORTY SEVEN AND FORTY
EIGHT PASS RETAIN.
WE ARE FILE ITEM FORTY NINE SB
FOUR EIGHTEEN CORKERY.
SENATE BILL FOR EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND ACTUALLY
TO THE PAYMENT OF CLAIMS AGAINST
THE STATE MAKE AN APPROPRIATION
THERE FOR TO COME THERE AND SEE
THEIR UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MS GONZALEZ EMAIL THANK YOU SB
FOUR EIGHTEEN WITH APPROPRIATE
TWENTY SEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL FUND TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THE
PAYMENT OF CLAIMS AGAINST THE
STATE WHICH HAVE BEEN APPROVED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
DEPARTMENT.
OF FINANCE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS BECAUSE ALL SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TALLY THE VOTE EYES SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I
SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO ON THE BILL THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEMS FIFTY THROUGH FIFTY TO
PASS.
AND RETAIN.
WHERE FILE AT A FIFTY THREE SB?
ONE FORTY ONE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS.
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY.
MR LACKEY ON THE MAINTENANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT A MEMBERS FOR
SB ONE FORTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
CENTER BATES.
THESE MEMORIES ARE.
AS YOU MIGHT PROJECT TECHNICAL
IN NATURE.
AND THEY SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKING.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE PHONE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
DOCTOR THE BILLS HAVE TO PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE.
FILE ITEMS FIFTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE
AND FIFTY SIX PASS.
AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN IS
SB.
TWO TO FOUR CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR GROVE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO GRAND THEFT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO RISE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR GROW FOR SB.
TWO TO FOUR CREATES A SEPARATE
CRIME FOR AGRICULTURAL GRAND
THEFT.
DIRECT SPINES COLLECTED BACK
INTO EXISTING RURAL CRIME
PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS OF ALL HAD
TANGIBLE RESULTS ALLOWING
NEIGHBORING JURISDICTIONS TO
SHARE INFORMATION CRIME
STATISTICS DURING INVESTIGATIONS
OF RURAL CRIME AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECOVERY.
EFFORTS.
THE COUNTIES THAT PARTICIPATE IN
THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE THE
FRESNO CA.
KERN KINGS MADERA MERCED
MONTEREY SAN BENITO SANTA
BARBARA SANTA CRUZ SAN JOAQUIN
CHANNELS OBISPO AND STANISLAUS.
FOR FARMERS WHO ARE LOSE OF SAY
A TRACTOR IN -- AGRICULTURAL
STEP TO BE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR SMALLER OPERATIONS
IT REALLY CAN BE CAREER ENDING
BY MAKING AGRICULTURAL STAFFED A
SEPARATE CRIME.
SB TWO TO FOUR INSURERS BETTER
TRACKING OF THE CRIMES
ADDITIONALLY BY REQUIRING THE
FINES COLLECTED THE DEPOSIT INTO
EXISTING RURAL CRIME PREVENTION
PROGRAMS THIS BILL WILL HELP
FARMERS AND COMMUNITIES.
PREVENT AND RECOVER FROM THIS
TYPE OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THERE WAS PATTERSON.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CIRCLE OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FIFTY EIGHT THROUGH.
SIXTY FOUR PASS A RETAIN
.
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT SB.
EIGHTEEN PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT ARE ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY ONE THAT IS SB
[inaudible]
TWO THIRTY THREE COVERAGE.
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO CRIME [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THESE THE RETENTION IS
KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU MAY OPEN
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY AS A CO
AUTHOR TO PRESENT S. B. TWO
THREE THREE BY SENATOR WIENER.
THIS BILL IMPROVES THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF SEX WORKERS BY
PROHIBITING THE ARREST OF AN
INDIVIDUAL FOR MISDEMEANOR
PROSTITUTION RELATED CRIMES WHEN
THEY COME FORWARD TO REPORT
THEMSELVES THE VICTIM OR WITNESS.
OF SPECIFIED VIOLENT CRIMES.
SB TWO THREE THREE ALSO ENSURES
THAT THE POSSESSION OF CONDOMS
MAY NOT BE USED AS EVIDENCE TO
ARREST TO PROSECUTE SOMEONE FOR
PROSTITUTION RELATED CRIMES.
THE CRIMINALIZATION OF
PROSTITUTION HAS HAD DEVASTATING
AFFECTS ON SEX WORKERS WHETHER
THEY ARE SELLING BY CHOICE
CIRCUMSTANCE OR BY FORCE.
AS A DIRECT RESULT OF THIS
CRIMINALIZATION ALL SEX WORKERS
ARE VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIMES
AND A DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH
RATES.
OVER 60% OF ALL SEX WORKERS HAVE
BEEN VIOLENTLY OR SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED WHILE WORKING.
IN ORDER TO APPREHEND THESE
DANGEROUS CRIMINALS AND RAPISTS
THAT ARE PREYING ON THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION WE MUST
PRIORITIZE THE SAFETY OF SEX
WORKERS.
OVER CRIMINALIZING THEM SO THAT
THEY CAN FEEL SAFE ENOUGH TO
REPORT THESE VIOLENT CRIMES
WITHOUT FEAR THAT THEY WILL IN
TURN BE ARRESTED FOR PROSECUTE
XIN.
THE PROSECUTION AND PROSTITUTION
ALL THESE PEAS.
CONDOMS WHICH ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HELP STOP THE
SPREAD OF INFECTION ARE STILL
USED AS A TOOL TO CRIMINALIZE
SEX WORKERS BY USING THEM AS
EVIDENCE WHEN PROSECUTING
SOMEONE FOR SEX WORK.
WE NOW HAVE REPORTS WHERE
TRAFFICKERS IN AN EFFORT TO NOT
LOSE MONEY WILL DENY THEY'RE
VICTIMS ACCESS TO CONDOMS TO
MINIMIZE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY WILL BE CONTACT WITH
CONDOMS AND ARRESTED FOR SEX
WORK.
NOT SURPRISINGLY DATA FROM
MULTIPLE COUNTRIES LINK THIS
CRIMINALIZATION OF CONDOMS WITH
A FIVE FOLD INCREASE IN THE RISK
OF HIV OR OTHER SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS.
ARRESTING SEX WORKERS WHEN
THEY'RE REPORTING THEMSELVES AS
A VICTIM OF RAPE OR USING
CONDOMS OF AS EVIDENCE TO CHARGE
SOMEONE WITH SEX WORK IS BAD
PUBLIC POLICY AND DOES NOT
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY.
IT IS DETRIMENTAL TO OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH OUTCOMES.
SB TWO THREE THREE IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR ENTIRE
STATE BY PROTECTING SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE AND EXPLOITED
CONSTITUENTS THIS BACK BILL
PASSED OUT OF ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY.
UNANIMOUSLY WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MR MURATSUCHI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER.
YOU KNOW I I SUPPORT THE GOALS
OF OF THIS BILL [inaudible]
IT'S A TRYING TO PROVIDE AN
INCENTIVE TO REPORT MORE SERIOUS
CRIMES.
IT'S TRYING TO PROTECT.
VULNERABLE WORKERS THIS QUESTION
THE SAX INTO THE INDUSTRY.
AND IS TRYING TO PROMOTE CONDOM
USE. TO ACHIEVE OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH GOALS.
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK MANY OF
US INCLUDING MYSELF.
SUPPORTED THE BILL.
THAT THE OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
GLENDALE AUTHOR LAST YEAR
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY TO FORTY THREE WHICH
PROHIBITED THE USE OF THIS TYPE
OF EVIDENCE TO PROSECUTE
[inaudible]
THESE SERB.
PROSTITUTION RELATED CASES WHEN
THEY ARE REPORTING MORE SERIOUS
OR VIOLENT FELONIES.
MY CONCERN HERE IS THAT THIS IS
CREATING A BAD PRECEDENT AND
THIS IS BAD PUBLIC POLICY.
WHEN WE START BANNING CATEGORIES
OF EVIDENCE?
AND AND CATEGORIES OF ARRESTS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO BAN
[inaudible]
THE ARRESTS.
YOU KNOW TO PROHIBIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS OFFICERS
FROM ARRESTING ANYONE WHEN
THEY'RE REPORTING.
MORE SERIOUS CRIMES.
WHAT?
I HAVE A QUESTION MY MIND AS TO
YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF
PROTECTIONS ARE THERE.
TO PREVENT SOMEONE FROM JUST
REPORTING.
NO OR CLAIMING TO BE A WITNESS
FOR MORE SERIOUS CRIME IN ORDER
TO AVOID.
THE ARREST FOR THE CRIME THAT
THEY WERE.
PERSONALLY ENGAGED IN
[inaudible]
AND SECOND. TO BAN.
AN ENTIRE CATEGORY OF EVIDENCE.
AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE [inaudible]
PROCEDURES.
FOR EVIDENCE TO BE EXCLUDED
PRIMARILY ON THE BASIS OF
CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS WHETHER
THERE IT'S A VIOLATION OF THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT RIGHT AGAINST
SERVICE SEIZURE.
UNREASONABLE SEARCHES SEARCHES
AND SEIZURES.
BUT I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY.
PRESIDENT OF IN A BANDING AN
ENTIRE CATEGORY OF EVIDENCE AND
SO.
I SUPPORT THE GOAL OF THIS BILL.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT IS CREATING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FORMER
PROSECUTION [inaudible]
PROSECUTORS.
AND FOR THAT REASON I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF SP TWO THREE
THREE I RISE IN SUPPORT.
UP.
WE DO ALL SORTS OF THINGS ON
RULES OF EVIDENCE -- AND A LOT
OF THAT IS DONE FOR REASONS OF
PROTECTING THE GET PEOPLE
AGAINST SELF INCRIMINATION.
OUR THIS BY LOOKING AT CONDOMS
CAUGHT.
WE ARE JUST SAYING IT'S
HEALTHIER IF THEY CARRY THEM
THAT IF THEY DON'T.
AND THAT SHOULD AND RIGHT NOW.
I SPOKE WITH THE GROUP YOU MIGHT
HAVE SEEN THEM AT THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION -- IT WAS A
GROUP OF PEOPLE SAYING A SEX
WORKER ST SEX WORK IS REAL WORK.
AND IT IS A REAL PROBLEM THAT
THOSE FOLKS.
AS THEY TELL ME ARE SCARED TO
CARRY CONDOMS SO WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY GO AHEAD WITH THE
BELL.
I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT IT IS
ALREADY A CRIME TO REPORT
SOMETHING THAT'S AS A CRIME THAT
ISN'T.
AND I THEREFORE DO NOT THINK WE
WILL GET PEOPLE REPORTING CRIMES
THAT ARE NONEXISTENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK GOD QUIRK.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
MS KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FROM BOTH
THE NORTH AND THE SOUTH FOR
THEIR COMMENTS ON THIS BILL --
AS WE HAVE GONE THROUGH OVER A
DECADE OF HAVING CONVERSATIONS
PUBLIC POLICY CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT SAFE SEX WE CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO NOW SUGGEST THAT
YOU SHOULD NOT BE CARRYING
PROTECTION WITH YOU WHEN YOU ARE
ENGAGED IN SEXUAL ACTIVITY --
HAVING CONDOMS ON YOUR PERSON
SHOULD NOT BE PERCEIVED AS A
CRIME AND GENERALLY SPEAKING --
PROSECUTORS HAVE ADDITIONAL
EVIDENCE WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO
THEY'RE CHARGING OTHER THAN JUST
A COUPLE OF CONDOMS IN SOMEONE'S
POCKET I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
THIS BILL IS BEING SUPPORTED.
BY THE DA'S FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ALAMEDA AND SAN FRANCISCO
AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS IS
GOOD POLICY THIS IS ABOUT
TRADING A MISDEMEANOR FOR A
FELONY.
AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ENCOURAGE WITNESSES TO COME
FORWARD IN AN EFFORT TO SEEK
JUSTICE AGAINST VIOLENT
CRIMINALS THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL
WILL DO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
AND WITH THAT CLERK WILL OF THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF OUT
.
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE IT IS A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
A VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING HEARING NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A COULD
SECOND HONOR.
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
ACTUALLY TO FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THE
THIS IS CONSENT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
HELLO BUT I SEVENTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
LOCAL READ THE REMAINING ITEM ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION SIX ISIS.
SEVENTY FIVE NO [inaudible]
ZERO ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY JULY SECOND CHECK IN
SESSION.
WHEN STATE?
JULY THIRD CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY JULY FOURTH.
HOLIDAY INDEPENDENCE DAY.
AND FRIDAY JULY FIFTH
[inaudible]
FLOOR SESSION.
IS AT ONE THIRTY PM [inaudible]
ON FRIDAY
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE AN ITEM I BUT WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE AT A GERMAN SAID MEMORY I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS.
AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AT THIS TIME OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. TO THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER OR OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
TO THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED A GERMAN TO MEMORY THE
QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ASK AT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED.
IN THE MEMORY OF NAY WONG OF
MARYSVILLE.
WHO DIED ON MAY TWENTY NINTH AT
THE AGE OF?
NINETY MAY WONG STORY IS YET
ANOTHER GREAT EXAMPLE OF AN
IMMIGRANT WHO MADE CALIFORNIA
BETTER.
AND MADE OUR COUNTRY BETTER.
SHE WAS BORN IN TAISHAN CITY IN
THE PROVINCE OF GUANGDONG CHINA
IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT SHE
SUFFERED POVERTY AND HUNGER IN
HER HOME COUNTRY.
BEFORE ARRIVING IN THIS COUNTRY
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX IT MARYSVILLE.
MAY WONG WORKED IN HER PARENTS'
RESTAURANT WAITING TABLES WITH A
TODDLER STRAPPED TO HER BACK.
THAT TODDLER WAS BILL.
ONE MY POLITICAL ADVISER AND
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF.
WELL SHE TOOK CLASS WHILE SHE
WORKED SHE TOOK CLASSES AT NIGHT.
AND IN LESS THAN A DECADE SHE
WAS READY TO OPEN HER OWN
RESTAURANT WITH HER HUSBAND.
SHE RAN MAMA'S CHINESE
RESTAURANT UNTIL RETIRING IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR MAY ONE DIED
PEACEFULLY IN HER SLEEP IN MAY.
AND THE SURVIVE SURVIVED BY FIVE
CHILDREN.
BILL.
JAMES LAURIE CAN.
AND ROBERT.
AND BY NINE GRANDCHILDREN.
SHE IN THE KURDS THE EDUCATION
OF ALL OF THEM.
AND MANY OF GONE ON TO EARN
ADVANCED DEGREES.
SHE LIVES LEAVE THEM BEHIND AS
PROUD AND ACCOMPLISHED OFFSPRING
AND SHE LEAVES US WITH A BETTER
WORLD.
I ASK YOU TO DURING HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MISTER GIBSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
JOURNEY IN MEMORY.
OF MY FRIEND DR W. JEROME FISHER
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE THE YOUNG
AGE OF NINETY FIVE YEARS OLD --
HE SERVED AS A SPIRITUAL LEADER
IN THE COMMUNITY FOR OVER SIXTY
TWO YEARS IN COMPTON.
DOCTOR FISHER ORGANIZED THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN CHURCH IN
COMPTON -- WITH THIRTEEN PEOPLE
WHICH BECAME.
THE LITTLE ZION MISSIONARY
BAPTIST CHURCH AND GREW TO
BECOME A GREATER DESIGN
MISSIONARY OF CHURCH FAMILY OVER
OVER -- TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS --
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP AND
DIRECTION OF HIS SON MICHAEL J.
T. FISHER.
DOCTOR FISHER RECEIVED HIS
DOCTOR DOCTOR DEGREE IN THEOLOGY
TO HONORARY DOCTORATE DEGREES OF
DIVINITY.
AND IN NUMEROUS AWARDS INCLUDING.
TO EVANGELISTS OF THE YEAR AWARD
HE SERVES HE SERVED ON THE
CENTURY FREEWAY AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP AND DIRECTION AND
APPOINTMENT OF THEN JERRY BROWN.
WAS A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE COMP
OF CONTENT ON THE COMMISSION TO
BUILD THE ONE OH FIVE FREEWAY.
IN ONE OF HIS PROUDEST MOMENTS A
PASTOR FISHER -- WAS THE OPENING
SPEAKER WHO PROVIDED THE PRAYER
FOR THE ONE HUNDRED CONGRESS IN
WASHINGTON DC.
A DOCTOR FISHER WAS A RENOWNED
PASTOR INCREASE ALL OVER THE
WORLD PLACES AS SO CALLED JAPAN
AND ALSO THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLICANS AND JUST TO NAME A
FEW.
HERE SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE NORMA
J. FISHER AND HIS CHILDREN --
THREE OF HIS CHILDREN ARE NOW
GOSPEL PREACHERS -- STE HE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HE WILL BE MISSED AND IT NEARLY --
HIS LEGACY WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE
ON I HAD OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT
WITH HIM IN THE HIGH HOSPITAL.
AND AS SOON AS I GOT TO THE DOOR
HE SAYS WHERE'S YOUR BIBLE.
AND I SAID I DON'T HAVE IT -- I
DO HAVE IT IS ON MY PHONE HE'S
IT TURNED.
TO SECOND TIMOTHY.
OF FOURTH VERSE SIX OR SEVEN
CHAPTER.
AND I BEGAN TO READ AND IT WILL
IT REEKS OF PERMISSION EVERY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION I HAVE FOUGHT.
I'VE FOUGHT A GOOD FIGHT.
I HAVE FINISHED MY COURSE I HAVE
KEPT THE FAITH.
AND HE GAVE ME A THUMBS UP.
AND WE BEGAN TO TALK -- AND THEN
OUR FATHERS DAY GOD CALLED HIM
HOLD AROUND FIVE O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU IS WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY.
OF A DOCTOR W. JEROME FISHER.
THANK YOU MISS GIVES A MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DEATHS REPORTED IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUESTS TO ADJOURN A MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIVE
THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM FORTY ONE SB TWO
THIRTY THREE CRACKLE POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WISH TO VOTE
TAKES [inaudible]
FIFTY FOUR CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS.
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SINGER IN A FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MISTER CHANG MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL FRIDAY JULY FIFTH.
AT ONE THIRTY PM PLEASE NOTE THE
SPECIAL TIME.
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED WE ARE JR